[Music]
a nation at war sends its best and
strongest men to fight those who
actually go to the front and do
hardships and dangers unequaled in any
of their past experience courage pride
and loyalty to their comrades support
them in battle
but there are fierce demands upon their
emotional resources
day after day they live in danger
they see their best friends cut down
shattered by shrapnel and burned by the
fire of the enemy they see the grinding
horror of mutilating death
[Music]
finally these mounting pressures may
overwhelm the strongest personalities
[Music]
these men are the residue of the battle
for every four men wounded one soldier
will become a psychiatric casualty such
men may be shaking or crying but more
often they are just very tired and dirty
and depressed a few words with them show
that they are out of a fight for a time
at least they are unnerved and have no
initiative they're not quitters but are
truly ill a plan for treating these men
was developed in the Mediterranean area
this plan involves treatment at three
levels division Army and base the
psychiatric casualty is filtered back to
the battalion aid stations from there
they are taken by ambulance together
with the physically sick and the wounded
back to the division clearing station
upon arrival they are promptly
segregated
we have learned as many of these men
with neurotic reactions can recover
quickly when the battle situation has
been left behind temporarily
fundamentally we must depend for this
recovery on the patient's own
recuperative powers but these powers can
best be exercised away from a hospital
atmosphere consequently also called
exhaustion cases are taken immediately
to the nearby training and
rehabilitation center there they will
see no wounded only men who are actively
participating in their own recovery they
see men being retrained for duty
the emphasis is on showing a man what he
can do rather than on worrying about
what he has failed to do
soon after arrival each soldier is
interviewed briefly by the psychiatrist
here is a mild anxiety state sorry
soldier what's your trouble
well we got into pretty heavy showing a
couple of langar killed not happening
I was in charge to try to straighten him
in out I got him straightened out
another show came in right alongside of
me pick me up and threw me off this race
broke my rattle well when I came down
next thing I know I was out before would
slope and he'd tell me I'd be down
stopping me
and I was trying I don't know as much
between times I get the show game is
ghost means all the time you kind of
stay there
got me back off forward slope I was
crying and it took me back
have you tagged by the medics back here
how do you feel now take your own cycle
what do you mean that's hard to explain
that it
nobody shake a little bit on the outside
but on the inside I feel more inside and
they do outside it's like a boiling
feeling you just can't explain any other
trouble week that's all did you run
after you picked yourself up I must have
certain hand way out there 150 yards
ahead of the rest of the company I don't
know how I got out there otherwise
I don't under that very clearly I
haven't you been in the Army how long
have you been overseas one years and in
combat nine months you've been a
rifleman all this time is up on the line
yes sir
ever been wounded yes that little bit
twice how did you feel after you first
got wounded first time pretty heavy
right off the line though jumpy jumpy
when you came back to your outfit well
sir I'm back on the line again I I felt
a little more nervous than what I did
before I was ever wondered how that's
the second time second time was really
worth it you noticed your nervousness
increasing yes soon ever since I've been
wounded every time at the first acquire
we'd ever wounded oh it's alright I
never had any trouble at all and after
being wounded once why I got a little
jumpy in the room more cautious and then
second time right after that I don't
feel just I gotta have it anymore like I
used to
well no soldier I think that you've had
a pretty common experience of having a
shell land near you
shake you up a little gives you more of
a fight than anything else there's panic
that you had sort of a safety valve that
we all have what we're going to do with
you is keep you here for a couple of
days give you something to make you
sleep for a little while we've got some
good chow here let you play some poker
with the boys I'll see you a couple of
days later that's all all right
in this first interview a beginning is
made in helping the man to orient
himself in helping him to understand
that his experience is neither unique
nor hopeless he's now given a chance to
pull himself together resting and lying
about for a couple of days with only
moderate sedation one of the things
which helps him most is the chance to
reestablish normal social contacts he
can enjoy the simple pleasure of writing
a letter or the luxury of a good shave
he must be up for every meal and the
food is the best that can be provided a
sense of physical well-being is
encouraged by filling his hungry stomach
or unlike the nervous civilian most of
these men have ravenous appetites after
two such days of relaxation each man is
again seen briefly by the psychiatrist
how do you feel now also I've calmed
down a little bit feel a little bit
better
I got fairly good sleep last night have
any medicine no sir
slept well without it yes how do you
feel about this place well sir get away
from the noise and she'll fire and
everything else get that tension off boy
feel much better well I think you're
going to be all right in another 3 or 4
days what we're going to do put you in
the training center where you'll have
marches hike you'll get a chance to get
your confidence back when's the last
time you shot your rival before
yesterday sir well we'll give you a
chance to shoot it give you a chance to
get out there and get back into shape
again you'll be warm and you'll be dry
you'll be going back to duty in about
five days it would be ok remember what
you had was just a safety valve which
everyone has and which blows off steam I
think you were more scared about it than
anything else
anything out
those men who are well enough moved into
nearby pup tents where they live with
other men as soldiers in training and
not as medical patients at this stage
the men once more are given rifles and
field equipment which must be cared for
properly they are given exercises
regularly to get them back in good
physical condition they begin to act and
look and feel like combat soldiers once
more as they go through hard daily
battle training the ruins of recent
battlefields lend realism to
reconditioning maneuvers intelligent
leadership by battle-tested officers and
noncoms contributes greatly to the
recovery of these soldiers here is a
situation in which they can prove to
themselves how well and able they have
again become after four or five days of
training they are seen again by the
psychiatrist you've been here through
the training period we've had about
seven days away from the line yes how do
you feel now I feel good sir ready to go
back yes
how'd you like training how are your
nerves steady feel that you're ready to
go up there and do a job yes okay good
luck to you
all right thanks sir these men are again
combat soldiers normally 40 to 50
percent respond to the treatment which
has been shown and returned to full duty
of these 80 percent remain on combat
duty and a majority are rated by their
officers as average or better than
average soldiers they go back to their
fighting job as new men who know what
they can expect of themselves a lesser
number however are more seriously ill
and require a different handling this
man with a reactive depression is such a
soldier what's your trouble
I just can't stand seeing people kills I
can't hear you I can't stand seeing
people killed
did you see people kill lots of what
lots of them
where did this happen well what happened
up there no forward slope German start
showing them your track could we get out
what happened to you I was lucky enough
to get under the bridge
showing quieted down this one crazy a
runaway how do you feel about that
leaving your buddies should be in a
stockade
well how do you feel right now you say
you ran away yes how do you feel about
that no I was doing
what were you afraid of
everything what in particular
what in particular
dead what dead and what than people
stand singing I can't hear you
cats dancing dead people what does that
do - scuse me
well dead people can't hurt you telling
myself off the years what I've been
telling myself birthday years but I
can't stand looking at me
are you afraid of dying
don't be afraid of getting hurt you feel
you have a job to do up there
when burner on I think that you'll need
a little more treatment you're pretty
jittery and jumpy now what I'm going to
do is send you back to another hospital
where you can get more rest and more
treatment and you'll be okay let's take
a few days we'll get you rested up and
you'll feel a lot better it is obvious
that this man is too ill to respond
quickly to treatment he is [ __ ] and
self accusatory his present condition
together with his past history of
neurotic fears leaves little hope of a
rapid recovery
another group of seriously shaken men is
composed of old veterans who have been
excellent soldiers but have reached the
limit of their endurance here we see a
chronic anxiety state which has been
labeled the old sergeant syndrome before
what thought this about
Shelly I guess I've been going I wonder
if in the army you owe me thirty four
months how long have you been overseas
29 30 month and we're through the
African campaign yes sir colonel
crossing yes sir
and you also ever lost any combat time
also well that gives you about 320 days
of combat yes well what do you think's
wrong with you Donna buzz buzz I could
go sergeant
do you think that you're sick so much I
can't stand the show anymore the last
time I pair up broke down the section to
lead don't know good tool
what do you mean you book down well
giving the last yellow ticket area had
me crying all night just gonna stand it
you know it just which way to turn or to
go well do you think you could go back
up there and do it down well I might
doubts suppose I gave you a direct order
well I guess I'm nothing I could do
about that but do you think you can't
make it the better quite chilled did you
do a job out of shell fire humbly if I
could how do you feel about leaving your
outfit I feel bad about it what nugget -
I can't eat him I get him killed getting
wounded just my good
you think you could take a job water
master unit for example believe so sir
how do you feel right now this moment
yes sir
so much better powers up there even the
best man can stand only so much in the
old veteran anxiety reactions become
chronic and fixed he gets to be
emotionally labile in combat losses
drive and judgment and may finally bring
disaster to his section often he will
hold on in the line until actually
ordered out by his Co he is sick and has
lost his effectiveness in combat though
he recovers composure rapidly behind the
lines he too must be evacuated well I'm
going to send you back to a hospital now
back there you'll be able to despoil go
further Thanks
these men and others too ill to be
returned promptly to combat duty are
evacuated to a centralized NP clearing
station located in the army area it is
set up as close to the front line as the
tactical situation permits this small
provisional hospital of 250 beds is
never handicapped by the rush of
surgical emergencies from battle unlike
the evacuation hospitals all its
facilities are reserved for the care of
psychiatric cases those cases who might
easily become chronic neurotics if they
are not treated promptly here they are
assigned to ward tents and as soon as
possible they are interviewed by a
psychiatrist the main club
here again is the depressed soldier who
was interviewed at the T&R Center
[Music]
biggest trouble is I can't stand
people could kill
all my life I can't kill anyone either
right
good
very
she'll allow me started seeing people
did something to me I couldn't stand it
last day
forward slow
what happened to you snow
the Germans to everything they had
I was lucky enough to get out of a
bridge
[Music]
watch them baking
running back
how much combat if you had it all
together
three days not three nights have you
always been this way
anything anyone here
this soldier has improved considerably
since his interview at the TNR center
yesterday he is less [ __ ] more alert
and responsive his depression is lifting
rest away from the battlefield a chance
to clean up and some chance to discuss
his problems have produced the usual
improvement and as a child personally
average to Charo and set
early already complex
every bad
what do you mean by that
Charlie
I just didn't think ours is
and very confident
have you ever gotten over that
how do you counter that Missouri
anybody or anything in your family life
I can feel that way
normal size thank you had any trouble
making friend
personality
we much of an athlete Seagal went to
sports to play with other children yes
why did you feel inferior and you count
four
how did you react when your child and
you saw blood or saw somebody hurt look
at it even when you're very young
and how does it make you feel remember
[Music]
first and soon
dad
[Music]
did you ever get into a fight
kids if I saw someone kill one
tell me about that
on our street by
speak up a little bit just to not know a
street fighter
Manny
everybody has gotten killed
how did that make you feel
[Music]
like I shouldn't fight
our unit
[Music]
what's your education been
a year of high school good
average what sort of work
salesman
later sir
great products
work for the same people
[Music]
and also
closer still
[Music]
you don't have any couple holding a job
best recommendations
are you married
instead of here
yes shift out day before I suppose
how did you feel about
[Music]
what do you think is wrong with it
corporal no sir
corporal this is a reaction which is one
which occurs very frequently in man in
combat and it's made you very
uncomfortable but it's not particularly
serious and you're going to get over it
won't affect you in civilian life we're
going to keep you here for a few days
we're going to explain things a little
better to you and when you understand
more about this you're going to feel a
good deal better and you're going to be
able to do your work a good deal better
nothing's going to get worse
promise you that
and loving bun in Philly and future life
here at the army NP clearing station
each patient who was evacuated from the
division is reinterviews here as earlier
it is pointed out that his reaction is
perfectly natural it is emphasized that
this reaction is temporary and that it
should leave no permanent after-effects
to Mars civilian adjustment he is
encouraged to start out on a course of
normal effective behavior instead of
chronic neuroticism natural social
contacts helped these men to find
themselves again the pleasure of a hot
shower adds to the feeling of a return
to an ordered existence relaxation with
other soldiers contributes to a feeling
of normality games reading and music are
available for those who wish them a
substantial number of men who couldn't
be returned from the division recover
sufficiently here at the Army NP center
to be set back to the front however the
majority need further treatment and will
not return to combat in the near future
for example a few tense uncertain
patients cannot start on their road to
recovery because the specific sources of
their anxiety have been obscured in the
depths of an hysterical amnesia this
patient is such a man he recalls readily
his anxiety during the first three days
of an attack on the Gothic line until he
was blown out of his foxhole but he
can't tell what happens from that time
until he came to in an aid station this
man will be given an intravenous
injection of a barbiturate which will
permit him to relive his combat
experiences constructively pentothal
sodium 1/2 gram in 10 cc's of distilled
water is injected while the patient
counts slowly
at the point we're counting becomes
confused the patient will be adequately
narcotized and highly suggestible
[Music]
you're back on the battlefield now what
are you doing what are you doing what
happens then what happens then you're in
your hole
watch out those shells are coming what
ah [ __ ]
what are you doing you're in your home
now
what's happening yes the shells are
coming in where are you there's nobody
there what do you do then
pairing hitch to after I go into another
[Music]
what do you do then
we hug give me here
[Music]
what happened then we take a ridge
master didn't let him earn my company we
taking it yes
this is coming comrades hell
and she goes your best buddy you want to
be comment
I come
we come together 5050 for the rush they
threw their weapons away come back
nothing to make a goddamn difference to
us we share I'd like to get my hand
[Music]
give me a new dog moochers done
yes I'm here
[Music]
in their name and their need for me
[Applause]
dramatic precipitation into the patience
battle experiences results in the
reliving of the Forgotten scenes but the
therapist often may have to lead the
patient back to the subject in order to
get a consecutive story where'd you go
after they blew you out of your home for
the third time
German German tell me about
and they put me in the process
violent emotions are evoked frequently
accompanied by tears this have reaction
is usual but not always present in a
successful interview
[Music]
it's on down the trail coming to the aid
station I hear it
[Music]
[Applause]
as the patient wakes up he is forced to
repeat the newly remembered experiences
this ensures that the memories will be
available for later treatment other
cases present different therapeutic
problems here is a case of major
hysteria how long haven't you been
feeling well
it's hard for you to speak I know but
soon you will be better and you'll be
able to speak pronounced hysterical
patterns such as this dysphonia are not
common and where they do exist
early treatment has prevented the spread
of the hysterical reactions among other
patients take a cigarette
you will notice that much anxiety
remains evident in this case of hysteria
classical conversion hysteria with
complete repression of anxiety is not
too frequently seen even here however
the symptoms so dominates the man that
it must be removed before progress in
treatment of his anxiety is possible
speech disorders in general are very
resistant to therapy and this particular
case showed no change after three
interviews with pentathol it was finally
necessary to resort to the older method
of applying faradic stimuli to his
larynx and using strong suggestion only
then did his voice begin to improve
significantly and only then could his
basic problem be approached
are you feeling any better since you
came here
the thing I do you feel frightened
you'll feel better after you rest for a
while and I'll see you again soon some
patients are even more disturbed and
disorganized than this man for example
here is another type of severe anxiety
state with panic and confusion such
cases have been labeled pseudo psychotic
the term emphasizes the temporary nature
of the completely disorganized state
this rifleman was evacuated from the
front after his best friend had been
disemboweled by a shell fragment he
believes that he is still on the
battlefield
the noise in the background causes him
to grumble on the floor in an effort to
protect himself from imaginary shells
careful nursing care without sedation
will often stop this reaction and
restore contact with reality in a few
days
however packs and electroshock
treatments sometimes are necessary to
speed recovery men with this severe a
reaction frequently are found to have
had pronounced neurotic disabilities in
their past
here is another man with such a
background he is a chronic neurasthenic
who developed a brief episode of
complete disorganization while actually
on the battlefield however he was able
to compose himself rapidly when
evacuated to the rear his parents
separated when he was 2 his childhood
was unhappy and he had numerous minor
illnesses in combat he was terrified
after four days he developed a confused
panic state and had to be caught by an
aid man before he could be brought in
for care tell me why did you come into
the hospital
that under shelling
Oh tell me what you mean by that
Bonnie shell and about
[Music]
running
control mine yours
how did you feel
[Music]
it is possible that neither this man nor
the pseudo psychotic seen earlier should
have been sent into combat originally
and it is impossible to return them to
battle now however it must be remembered
that good and able soldiers also lose
their grip after long and hard combat
again we see a chronic anxiety state in
another veteran sergeant who can no
longer do his job in battle he feels so
guilty about this that he even refuses
to wear his stripes
he has been overseas 18 months and is
fought through the African and Italian
campaigns he was wounded once has
anything happened during the past few
weeks that sassette you particularly yes
what was that
or my friends and feel how did you feel
about that
the hardest and
why
well these things be
best friend the hands while I was there
we'd always been together since it's
going to company
we're very close friends do you have any
other friends left in the company or any
men who are with you in Africa nope
you're the last one how do you feel
about going back to duty if you had to
if I had to
I guess it has to do
how do you feel about making the
mannequin
[Music]
why not I'm saying goodbye to
you'd feel the shame to face this
sergeant is through in combat continued
an acute battle fear wounds loss of
friends guilt feeling and extreme
fatigue finally overwhelm the strongest
men however prompt psychiatric care
makes further hospitalization
unnecessary for many of them these men
on the road to recovery are sent to the
Army convalescent hospital here they are
promptly reclassified and sent to a
replacement Depot at the Depot they are
assigned to jobs in the rear area they
can do a useful job once again they can
go on fighting the war and what's more
important in doing so they regain their
sense of personal value there can be no
more effective occupational therapy
those who need further treatment are
sent back to the base section NP
hospital most of these men also can be
sent finally to the replacement Center
for assignment to jobs in the rear area
only a few are evacuated to the United
States less than 10% of all psychiatric
battle casualties continue to be so ill
that they must be sent home as patients
only 10% that's only one man in 10 - is
not able to continue in a useful job
overseas but the significant fact is
that about half of the psychiatric
battle casualties can be sent back to
actual combat this contrasts with the
early days of the war in Africa then
little or no psychiatric treatment was
available ahead of the base section
hospitals from which only 2% could be
returned to the fighting front but now
early psychiatric treatment is saving
thousands of men men who can continue
the fight today
men who will be the healthy citizens of
tomorrow
[Music]